and we're live all right welcome
everybody another quick Monday TGIM
stashing this is alex from trauma dance
salsa and i got a question for my master
my members that we want to make a video
on how do you take a vacation so she's a
youtuber she's building up her channel
she's had some success she's committed
to which is doing almost video a day now
on the channel and she wants to take a
two-week vacation to go to California
over Christmas and is worried about the
channel I don't think it's something
that we can all relate to write your you
want to build your business you want to
see a girl but you also need a break you
want to relax and take it easy little
bit so how to balance those two and so
we're gonna give our advice and what you
can do with starting with me all right
it goes first yeah I I think it's um I
mean I'm not too familiar with her work
it has to do with it has to do with uh
she she talks about her stuff I guess
and a little bit about you know growing
yourself um it's California for two
weeks i think it's you could kill two
birds one stone you take a trip you
announce it to your followers that
you're going there and you shoot a
couple videos it's gonna be great a sort
of a kind of neat you a Eric chuckling a
film is gonna give a really fresh to
your blog right I'm imagining that you
regularly record your videos in one
location or maybe a couple familiar
locations so having that chain followers
with you on more value I think it's
gonna increase people of fellowship
forward for your blog and for your
YouTube channel so that's my scholarship
photoshop is it worth it increased your
fellowship we can make that you could
trend that yeah okay so a couple of tips
one uh make the videos ahead of time
this is something I can resonate with
I've done a number trips to california
no I'm actually not here next week I'm
not you next week oh I'm not here next
week and going to Microsoft new client I
have to go do a tour of their facilities
and so I'm missing my video filling day
which is always on Wednesday and so what
I'm doing is this week I'm going to be
filming not all the pieces but a number
the pieces ahead of time so do a little
bit more planning preparation have it
done ahead
I'm that usually helps too I always film
alam away and I don't let it become this
huge beast that like you don't do a
vacation because you're so busy working
uh it's always a more personal note and
the editing is always less right so when
I go to see Microsoft I think they're in
Seattle I'm going to be filming some of
my i'm thinking the end stresses in the
morning i usually do it either from the
hotel room or walking like I'm walking
on the way to get to their head office
I'll do it just walking and talking and
so it's not a set piece like I usually
do but it's different like its variety
it's good not just to be always in the
same yeah setting like you talked about
right and people don't expect as much in
terms of editing and perfectionism I
know you're a perfectionist at least the
person asks questions super perfections
people don't expect that same level
folly winking your way as long as you
you don't try to put up a front you
don't you don't try to pretend like
you're still home and usual recording
settings but you let people know hey i'm
on vacation california use a quick
message for you guys and so you can do
shorter videos you can do less editing
and film while your way i think you know
i try to use it as i try to record
enough in advance so that the ones that
I'm doing on vacation don't feel like
work I don't feel like I have to go do
these like I get to do a cool video in a
different setting I like it I add some
some fun um and then my last point was
to make an announcement and so you know
if you're super stiff you don't want to
do anything just want to chill and relax
then just tell your audience listen I'm
gonna be away for two weeks have a great
Christmas I'll see you back or stepping
it up again and in January whatever it
is right you can make that announcement
and then even if you feel like adding
like you miss it it's good to miss your
business every now and then right if you
miss it you could always you know pull
up your phone and say hey guys i miss
you guys thinking of you i'm thinking of
you here in from California you know and
whatever message you have that you want
to give you can always add that in
people won't expect it but it's a great
addition in I think the key though is
making sure that you're not
well I'm feeling like you're not
enjoying your vacation you're stressed
out because that kind of defeats the
purpose those are my good thoughts you
got anything else I know I thought that
was great yeah I guess the last thought
this isn't always manageable but planet
around the slow times in business yeah
right so this is probably good time for
you to go away right December it's going
to be slower down um whatever business
you have you want to plan around the
season so you not missing out on yep
Orton things right if you're getting
tons of email you're getting 10 look
comment and you're not checking it you
try not to check it there's gonna be
really hard you're gonna want to check
and see what's happening and get on the
details so that's it thank you Alex
Charlie excelsa what we're doing a
faster and for those who watch you don't
know about the mastermind group you can
check it out in the link in description
have an amazing Monday and we talk to
you soon stop